Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. First as tragedy, second as farce. And today we're looking at the farcical angle of things, both the history of comedy and the way in which history itself has been made the subject of comedy. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History with me, Tom Holland, and my straight man, the Ernie Wise, to my Eric Morecambe, Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic, how are you? I'm very well, thank you, Tom. I prefer to think of myself as... I mean, what are we? We're basically Laurel and Hardy, aren't we? Somebody said that on Twitter, that we would be perfect for playing Laurel and Hardy, so I'll take that.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听各系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。历史事件初次出现时是悲剧，第二次出现时则是闹剧。而今天，我们要探讨的是历史滑稽的一面，既有喜剧的历史，也有历史本身如何成为喜剧题材的内容。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，我是汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），旁边是我的捧哏搭档、我心中的埃里克·莫克姆（Eric Morecambe）的厄尼·怀斯（Ernie Wise）——多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。多米尼克，你好吗？我很好，谢谢你，汤姆。我更愿意把自己看作……我的意思是，我们算什么？我们基本上就是劳莱与哈台（Laurel and Hardy），对吧？推特上有人这么说过，说我们非常适合扮演劳莱与哈台，所以我就当是这么回事了。
Ernie Wise, I'm not so sure. Silent comedy on podcasts, I don't know, maybe not so good. And you know, Dominic, what we really need is the help of a man who has made a living out of making people laugh, often with a keen eye on history. I'm here, I'm here.
厄尼·怀斯，这点我可不太确定。播客里的默剧，我不知道，也许效果没那么好。你知道的，多米尼克，我们真正需要的是一个以逗笑为生的人的帮助，而且他通常对历史有着敏锐的洞察力。我在这儿，我在这儿。
Can you think of anyone? I'm here. Yeah, I mean... Apart from yourself. Apart from yourself. It's the obvious man. Al Murray, known also as his alter ego, the pub landlord. And increasingly these days, as one half of the podcasting double act fronting, we have ways of making you talk about the Second World War with some other bloke whose name slips me.
你能想到谁吗？我在这儿。对，我是说……除了你自己之外。除了你自己。这显而易见嘛。阿尔·默里（Al Murray），也就是他的化身“酒吧老板”（the pub landlord）。而且如今越来越广为人知的是，他是播客双人组的半壁江山，和另一个我记不起名字的家伙一起主持《我们有办法让你开口》（We Have Ways of Making You Talk），专门讲第二次世界大战。
Al, welcome to a podcast. Must be unusual experience for you being on a podcast. Well, it's very peculiar being, I mean, as it were, on the receiving end. Being the butt of the joke on this occasion, I suppose. Thanks for having me. I've heard several of your... The one about the outbreak of the origins of the First World War, though. God, I had things to yell at my iPhone listening to that.
阿尔，欢迎来到播客。对你来说，上播客一定是个不寻常的体验。嗯，这感觉非常奇特，因为我是作为，怎么说呢，接受审判的一方。这一次我成了笑柄，我想是这样的。谢谢你们邀请我。我听过你们好几个……不过讲第一次世界大战爆发起源的那期，天哪，我听的时候简直恨不得冲着我的iPhone大喊大叫。
No, no no no no that was all good oh yeah absolutely good stuff oh i mean as marxist interpretations go dominic oh very good very good so where should we start tom i think we i'll tell you what let's start with um the the funny the first funny book I ever read about history, Al, was 1066 and all that. And that's actually, for a lot of people, that's the sort of... the ur-text of sort of funny history
不，不，不，不，那期挺好的，哦，对，绝对是好东西，哦，我的意思是，就马克思主义的解读而言，多米尼克，哦，非常好，非常好。那我们该从哪里开始呢，汤姆？我想，我来告诉你吧，阿尔，我读过的第一本关于历史的趣味书籍是《1066和这一切》（1066 and All That）。对许多人来说，这其实就是那种……幽默历史或者说滑稽历史的“原典”。
or history as funny. Is it still funny, do you think? Well, yes, I think it probably is. I mean, after... I'm exactly the same. That was the first funny history book that was sort of given to me. I had R.J. Unstead's Looking at History, which was a sort of picture book with, you know,
或者把历史当成笑话。你觉得它现在还搞笑吗？嗯，是的，我想它大概还是挺搞笑的。我是说，毕竟……我的情况完全一样。那是别人送给我的第一本趣味历史书。我读过R·J·安斯特德（R.J. Unstead）的《看历史》（Looking at History），那是一本图画书，里面有，你知道的，
with Mott and Bailey castles in it and Roman underfloor heating and all the sort of kind of the imaginative framework that I still have about the Middle Ages middle ages and before although we don't call it that anymore do we anyway um uh and and i had that and i had 1066 and all that an awful lot of the uh stuff i read in 1066 and all that i probably encountered before i then studied it properly so my understanding the civil war pretty much comes from uh sellers and yeatman rather than rather than you know brilliant people like uh blair worden i mean i i very much or christopher hill or whoever i very much am the roundheads were the were terrible people the right idea and the cavaliers were
里面有莫特与贝利城堡（Motte and Bailey castles）、罗马的地暖，还有各种我至今仍用来构建中世纪以及更早时期想象框架的东西，尽管我们现在已经不这么叫了，不管怎样，嗯，我有那本书，还有《1066和这一切》。我在《1066和这一切》里读到的很多东西，大概在我正式学习历史之前就已经接触过了。所以我对内战的理解，很大程度上来自于塞勒斯和耶特曼（Sellers and Yeatman），而不是来自于，你知道的，像布莱尔·沃登（Blair Warden）这样才华横溢的人。我的意思是，我非常赞同——或者克里斯托弗·希尔（Christopher Hill）之流——我非常坚定地认为：圆颅党人是观念正确但行为糟糕的混蛋，而保王党人则是
nice people with the wrong idea you know and that that good king bad king good thing bad thing a breakdown of history was was then how i was taught it which is after all why the book's so bloody funny is it's uh there was a fag paper between it and o-level history the way it was taught and i remember when i got to do my degree being set a tutorial question one week of was king john a bad king you think yeah what the hell is going on well of course well of course he was but richard the lionheart was a worse king but but um but you know that that the reason that book's funny i mean it's it's it's homer simpson it's funny because it's true you know that that book absolutely strikes
观念错误但挺不错的好人。你知道的，这种“好国王、坏国王、好事、坏事”的历史拆解方式，就是当时教给我的方法。这毕竟也是这本书为什么这么该死的好笑的原因：它和牛津初级中学水平的历史（O-level history）之间只隔了一张香烟纸的距离。我记得当我上大学时，某周的导师辅导课上被问到一个问题：“约翰王是一个坏国王吗？”你会想：这特么到底是怎么回事？好吧，当然，他当然是个坏国王，但狮心王理查是个更坏的国王。但是，但是……你知道，这本书之所以搞笑，是因为它就是——它简直是《辛普森一家》（Homer Simpson），它搞笑是因为它是真的。你知道的，这本书精准地直击了当时的传授历史的方式，而我觉得现在的历史已经不这么教了。你知道的，现在有了第一手史料，这些都是我女儿们需要去应付的东西。
hard at the way history certainly was taught and i don't think it's taught like that anymore you know there's primary sources now all that's the stuff that my daughters have bothered themselves with. But we growing up with that book and that and that parodied outlook and seeing that, you know, that after all, for historians, history is a playpen that they they lob toys at each other. And why can't it be for everyone else and and least of all humorists yeah i i remember the um the wave of egg kings that's that's how the dark ages were summed up yeah and um no matter how i try and purge that from my mind i do find it very difficult not to think it's like and william of orange anglo-saxon history william of orange is drawn as an orange isn't he and i can never get that out of my head when thinking about william some of it's very very direct um but why not so the um the the whole good thing and bad
但我们是在那本书、那种讽刺的视角下长大的，并且看到，对历史学家来说，历史其实是一个他们可以互相扔玩具的儿童乐园。为什么历史就不能属于其他人，尤其是幽默作家呢？我记得那种“蛋形国王”的浪潮，黑暗时代就是这么被概括的。对，而且不管我怎么努力把它从脑子里清除掉，我发现自己真的很难不去这么想，就像奥兰治的威廉——盎格鲁-萨克森历史中，奥兰治的威廉被画成了一个橙子，不是吗？每当我想起威廉时，这个形象就永远挥之不去。有些内容非常非常直白。但为什么不呢？整个“好事”与“坏事”的理论——我的意思是，基本上，大英帝国现在给人的感觉就是这样：推特上的人们在争论大英帝国究竟是一件好事还是一件坏事。而且它似乎真的没有什么改变。虽然，呃……你在最开始就提到了第一次世界大战，听着多米尼克满嘴胡言乱语的马克思主义陈词滥调。对，对，对。我没记错吧？我读《1066和这一切》已经是很久以前的事了，但它是不是刚好在第一次世界大战爆发前就结束了？
thing i mean basically that's what the british empire seems to be at the moment it's people on twitter debating was the british empire a good thing or a bad thing and it doesn't really seem to have changed although um you it's you mentioned the First World War right at the beginning, listening to Dominic with his nonsense Marxist spiel. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Am I right? It's quite a while since I read 1066 and all that, but doesn't it finish just before the First World War?
因为美国成了超级大国，然后历史就画上了句号。是的，确实如此。我的意思是，这就是福山（Fukuyama）的观点，只不过是针对20世纪10年代的，对吧？历史终结了。我的意思是，是的，但我认为还有续集。我不记得了，因为……对，确实有，对吧，阿尔？
Because America becomes top nation and then history comes to a full stop. Yes, it does. I mean, so it's Fukuyama, I mean, but for the 1910s, isn't it? History has ended. I mean, yes, but I think there is a sequel. I don't remember because the... Yeah, there is, isn't there, Al?
那是谁写的？哦，有一部新续集。有一本……接着说，宣传一下你自己的书吧。好吧，好吧。在这个播客里厚颜无耻地植入图书广告确实有点出格，这简直前所未有。是的，我去年在封城期间写了一本书，作为喜剧作家，我发现这本身极具挑战性。因为毕竟，当你写……
And who wrote that? Well, there's a new sequel. There's one that... Go on, promote yourself. Well, all right. I mean, shameless book plugging on this podcast would really be out of line it's unheard of uh uh yes i wrote a book last year during during lockdown which in itself was an extremely i found very very challenging as a as a comic writer because after all when you write
写单口喜剧演出和写书的区别在于，对于单口喜剧，你会——我通常会坐在办公室里写一些东西，或者在车里，通常是在去某处地点的路上。然后我会上台去试演。当你创作现场单口喜剧时，你其实是在和观众共同创作。他们就是合作创作者。他们就是，你知道的，他们就是克罗夫蒂或佩里（Crofty or Perry）之类的人。他们是会指出“不，这个不行”、“对，这个行”的另一个人。
a the difference between writing a stand-up show and writing a book is with a stand-up show you you'll i'll sit here in my office and write some or in a car, usually on my way somewhere. And then I'll go on stage and I'll try it. And when you write a live stand-up show, you co-write it with the audience anyway. They're the co-writer. They're the, you know, they're the Crofty or Perry or whatever. They're the other person going, no, that doesn't work. Yes, that works.
拓展这个想法并在此基础上构建。但写书你可做不到这一点。而且单口喜剧的另一特点是，你永远不会真正给它定稿。如果我带着一套巡演节目出去，我会演200场，而且每场都不一样，因为你总是在不断微调、不断修正、不断精简。而当你写完一本书，你把它交出去，那就完事了，除了编辑有时会指出你的语法错误或者某个笑话的前后顺序搞反了之外，你什么也做不了。所以，好吧，是的，我……它叫什么来着？《过去的一百年：给与取以及这一切》（The Last Hundred Years Give and Take and All That），这是有人委托我写的，而我的虚荣心
Extend that idea and build on it. But you can't do that with a book. And also the other thing with the stand-up show is you sign off on it you never sign off on it so if i take a touring show out i'll do 200 nights and it's always different every night because you're always permanently tweaking and always fixing and always able to streamline it whereas when you write a book you hand it over and that's it and you can't do anything about it apart from the you know um grammar being wrong or is that joke the right way around that you get back sometimes from an editor so so all right yes i i what's it called the last hundred years give and take and all that which i was commissioned to write and my vanity
要求我在书名里加上“这一切”。我不知道这算不算是个好主意，但要搞懂20世纪并试图把它写得搞笑，感觉就像是一件……不，实际上感觉完全是有可能的。真的吗？对。因为我猜《1066 and All That》之所以在第一次世界大战结束，是因为你不能把时间写得太近。它是什么时候写的？大概是20世纪30年代吧，所以从某种意义上说，时间太近了，对吧。嗯，我的确把书的结尾写到了1999年左右，因为当我在1987年去大学学习历史时，课程大纲是从1964年开始的，或者根据你的观点，历史是从1964年开始或结束的，再往后就不叫历史了。所以分水岭是1964年，当时我19岁，觉得那简直像个永恒，23年还是多少年。但现在实际上，23年前也不过是……你知道的，仅仅是90年代末，也就是我大女儿出生的时候。感觉就像上面的油漆还没干透一样。所以我有意非常明显地避开了写最近20年，因为一切都太近了。而且，作为一个有责任感的历史学家，现在对2010年代的事件下结论是不可能的，对吧，各位先生？我的意思是，我们需要把这留给我们的后人，你知道的，在下一个世纪里。各位先生？我的意思是，我们需要把这留给我们的后人，你知道的，在下一个世纪里。那是他们超越我们的工作。好吧，我们在这个播客里正好讨论过这个问题：历史是从什么时候开始写的？
demanded that i write in all that book. I don't know how good an idea it was, but getting to grips with the 20th century and trying to make it funny felt like something... Well, no, it actually felt like entirely possible, actually. Really? Yeah. Because I guess the reason that 1066 and all that finishes with the first world
而我的看法是，大约要在尘埃落定二三十年之后。对。好吧，我的意思是，你不能……以特朗普为例，他可能只是比较轻松的部分。你知道的，他可能只是施洗约翰。是的，我的意思是，你知道的，以特朗普为例，他可能只是……他可能只是比较轻松的部分。你知道的，他可能就是……他可能只是施洗约翰。是的，完全如此。在历史进程中。所以，试图在历史上去定义他、容纳他，我认为是愚蠢的做法。但是，对于塞勒斯和耶特曼的书，关于一战的那部分，我猜不仅是因为时间太近，还因为它带来的创伤太深。是的，我想是的，没错。
war is is that you couldn't have made that too close because when's it written it was written in 1930s i think so it would be too close in a way yeah um well i do i do wind the book down in sort of 1999 because i i i when i went when i went to university to study history in 1987 the curriculum began in 1964 or ended depending on you know history began or ended depending on your point of view no further back is history so the watershed moment was 1964 so which at the time when i was 19 felt like an eternity the 23 years whatever it was but now actually 23 years ago is you know is is only the is only the late 90s when my eldest daughter was born it feels like it feels like the paint hasn't dried on it yet so i did
所以，阿尔，我是说，你知道的，你的播客《我们有办法让你开口》。对。这暗示了，你知道的，这是一个笑话。这是一个双关语。关于喜剧和二战的主题，我的意思是，事实上，当你仔细看时，你会发现这方面已经有了惊人数量的作品。
shy away quite considerably from writing about the last 20 years because it's all too close and also you know as a as a as a responsible historian it's impossible to draw conclusions about the events of the 2010s yet isn't it gentlemen i mean we need to leave that to our antecedents you know that in the in the in the next century it, gentlemen? I mean, we need to leave that to our antecedents, you know, in the next century. It's their job to beat us. Well, we've had exactly this conversation on this podcast about when history, when you start writing history.
比如斯派克·米利根（Spike Milligan），他曾亲历这场战争，对吧？他写了一系列关于这段经历的精彩书籍。然后你有《老爸的军队》（Dad's Army），还有《Allo Allo》。考虑到二战带来的创伤、苦难、暴力和恐怖，关于它的喜剧作品数量多得惊人，难道不是吗？嗯，如果你反过来想的话，我觉得关于它的喜剧数量其实少得惊人。作为历史房间里的大象，二战是……所有的道路都通向它，无论向前还是向后，我认为……我的意思是这很有趣，我是说《Allo Allo》就是一个很好的例子。因为那毕竟是一部电视剧，它是对《秘密军队》（Secret Army）的恶搞，而不是对二战本身的恶搞。然后，如果……而《秘密军队》本身其实是在利用它自己的70年代二战题材老套路和理念，接着《Allo Allo》又对那些进行了讽刺，并进一步挖掘，我认为这相当……你知道的，这算不算后现代？我不知道，如果我们在80年代它热播时，我不知道我们是否被允许这样称呼它。但是，我的意思是，你知道的，米利根的战争回忆录是在他变老、开始追忆往事、试图消化和处理自己的经历时写的。因为毕竟，他的战争以……他的战争最终……
And my take on it was it's about 20, 30 years before you get some sense of the dust settling. Yeah. Well, I mean, you know, you can't... Trump, for instance, he might be the easy bit. You know, he might be John the Baptist. Yes, I mean, you know, you can't Trump, for instance, he might be he might be the easy bit. You know, he might be that he might be John the Baptist. Yes, exactly. In the in the historical process. And so to sort of try and contain him in a way historically, I think would be would be folly. You know, but with but with Sellers and Yateman, not not about the First World War, I'm guessing it's not just because it's so close, but because it was so traumatic. Yeah, I imagine so, yeah.
可以这么说，所有的经历最终汇聚于……他精神崩溃了，患上了战争神经官能症（battle fatigue），被撤出了前线。然后他回忆录的最后三本，讲述的就是他如何重整旗鼓准备回家。所以很明显，他在试图处理那段经历。但是《戈恩秀》（The Goon Show）——也就是他彻底爆发并……他是战后英国喜剧中最具影响力的喜剧声音。
And so, Al, I mean, you know, your podcast, We Have Ways of Making You Talk. Yes. There's a hint, you know, it's a joke. It's a pun. And the theme of comedy and the Second World War, I mean, actually, when you look at it, a surprising amount has been done.
——就是那个让他彻底爆发并传诵至今的节目，你知道的，他是战后英国喜剧中最具影响力的喜剧声音。我认为毫无疑问，他彻底打破了一切，他改变了一切。
So there's Spike Milligan, who fought in it, right? Series of kind of brilliant books about it. Then you have Dad's Army and then Alo Alo. And there is a quite, you know, considering the trauma, the suffering, the violence, the horrors of the Second World War. There is quite a surprising amount of comedy about it, isn't there? Well, I think there's a surprisingly small amount about it if you it's the other way around there's the you know it's the as the as the sort of historical elephant in the room the second world war is the it's the all roads lead to it forwards and back i think um and i mean it's interesting i mean hello hello is a case
他运用了当时其他人还没有完全理解的来自美国的元素，比如马克思兄弟（Marx Brothers）。当他来到50年代时，《戈恩秀》成了一部非凡的超现实主义讽刺剧，内容涉及战争、阶级、虚伪的上流社会人物榨取诚实老百姓的血汗（你知道的，格里·皮尔·范（Grype-Thynne）——那个由塞勒斯扮演的、说话油腔滑调的难以置信的滑头，他总是试图坑害剧中的那些蓝领角色），或者布勒德-诺克上校（Colonel Bloodnok）——一个无能的上流社会军官。这部剧是关于战争的，《戈恩秀》讲的就是战争，但他把它藏在眼皮底下，因为它把战争包装成了一场超现实主义的、疯狂的冒险。我认为米利根最有趣的地方就在于此：早在写那本关于战争的书之前，早在正面触及这个话题之前，他就已经在处理它了，他在……我无法消化你说的这一点，不过其中很多东西其实根基更深，比如可以追溯到《维普斯时报》（The Wipers Times）以及一战战壕里的幽默，当时人们也会拿将军和军官开玩笑，对吧？我是说，我不知道米利根对那些了解多少，但确实如此，我的意思是，任何战争都会产生幽默，或者任何你懂的……然后我们当然就会陷入争论：拿任何特定事物开玩笑究竟有多得体？归根结底，这些都是关于品味的问题，而不是别的什么。不过《维普斯时报》确实是一个绝佳的例子，它也展现了人们用以表达幽默的技术手段。这也是为什么我们知道《维普斯时报》，因为他们把它写了下来。而幽默往往是一种转瞬即逝的东西，存在于空气中，消失得无影无踪，转瞬即逝。所以很难确切地锁定究竟是什么在什么时候逗笑了人们。让我们深入探讨一下这个问题，就一小会儿，关于品味和什么才是得体的，因为这些问题不仅仅关乎……我们会不会被“取消”？我们得注意。但这些问题不仅关乎喜剧演员，也关乎历史学家、作家，或者任何以某种方式与人类经验打交道的人。所以让我们来谈谈当下最具争议的话题——奴隶制。你能想象创作一些搞笑内容或喜剧专场吗？这听觉上如此骇人，以至于你的第一本能是退缩，但这种事真的能做到吗？我不知道，这其实已经有人做过了。这已经被做过了。我……好吧，请说。好吧，这曾在《庞贝古城之上》（Up Pompeii）里出现过。我知道那是设定在2000年前，但弗兰基·霍华德（Frankie Howerd）扮演的就是一个奴隶。而这其中的关键在于，它非常具有文化素养，因为那正是罗马喜剧的形式——你知道的，那种厚颜无耻、对主人评头论足的奴隶。那是哪个年代播出的？70年代，我想。70年代，是的。当时它被认为完全没有任何问题。但那是因为那是另一种奴隶制，对吧？现在还会这样吗？是的，但我认为现在的人们对奴隶制比过去敏感得多。我在想，如果让你的主演喜剧演员扮演一个奴隶，
of point because that's after all is is about a piece of television it's a parody of secret army rather than of the second world war and then if but which which after all was trading on its own uh 70s second world war tropes and ideas and then aloha lowe's lampooning that and then digging into them even further which i think which i think's a quite you know is that is that post-modern i don't know if we i don't know if we're allowed to don't know if we would have been allowed to call it that in the 80s when it was on but but i i mean you know milligan's war memoirs are written uh when he when he starts getting old and he starts reminiscing and he starts trying to digest and deal with his experiences because after all the end with that his war his war culminates
这还会像在70年代那样毫无问题吗？我不知道。我的意思是，你大概比我更清楚……好吧，我的意思是，我现在可不敢把它拿到BBC一台去播。不。不。也许可以去第五频道（Channel 5）。问题是，好吧，问题在于，这些都是……
as it were it's all experience culminates with... He has a nervous breakdown, battle fatigue, is taken out of the line, and then the last three books of his memoirs are him piecing himself together to go home. And so, clearly, he was trying to deal with that. But the goon show, which is the thing where he busts open and... He's the most important comic voice
我的意思是，我认为非常有趣的是，这些归根结底都是关于品味的问题。而品味是会改变的。而且，你知道，一直以来都有这样一场争论。有趣的是，你把它框定成这样，因为在10周年以前，曾有一种观点认为喜剧的意义就在于突破界限。你知道的，你必须 edgy（前卫大胆），你必须打破界限。你知道的，在拉塞尔·布兰德（Russell Brand）、乔纳森·罗斯（Jonathan Ross）的“萨克斯门”（Sachsgate）丑闻期间，这些论点曾被搬出来为某些人辩护。相当严肃的人也曾搬出这个论点：喜剧的工作就是突破界限。然而每隔一段时间，就会有人跳出来说：“不是那些界限！对，对，对，但不是那些界限。”是的。是的，但谢谢你，不是那些界限。我们宁愿不要。
in British comedy post-war. is the thing where he bust open and read, you know, he's the most important comic voice, um, uh, in British comedy post-war. I think without, without any doubt, he, he breaks everything wide open. He changes everything.
而且，你知道，米利根当然也是如此。米利根花了十年时间把粗俗的名字塞进《戈恩秀》里，如果BBC的审查员发现了，就把它们删掉。你知道的，那些叫休·汉普顿（Hugh Hampton）、休·汉普顿、汉普顿威克（Hampton Wick——俚语指阴茎）的角色，这就是个大阳具的家伙。你知道的，他花了大把时间做这种事，因为那是当时的界限，也是他当时奋力抗争的界限。
He's using stuff from America that other people haven't quite got their heads round yet, like the Marx brothers. And he comes to the fifties and the goon show is this extraordinary surrealist satire about the war about class about um posh chaps skimming off honest folk um you know grit the fact that grip pipe thin who's the who's this incredible smoothie he talks like that played by sellers he's always trying to do over the essentially the blue collar characters in it or colonel blood knock who's
而且我认为，这里面有很大一部分纠葛，介于基本上属于品味问题的事物与被提升到原则高度的事物之间。通常情况下，这可能会是一片相当棘手的水域。不过我想说的是，作为一名从业的喜剧演员，这些事情远没有一半那么紧急——或者说，它们并不像我读到关于它们的文章时那样让我感到紧迫或担忧。你知道的，现实中人们只是在继续过日子，然后是那些围绕它撰写的文章。这正是我所说的那个飘渺变幻的世界。阿尔，我有个问题想问你。你谈到品味在变，界限也在变。这似乎意味着我们认为搞笑的东西也在变。真的是这样吗？好吧，当然是这样。比如说，有一个叫罗兰·勒·佩塔托（Roland le Petator）的丑角，他是亨利二世的御用雇员，对吧？由于他的放屁绝技，他在萨福克郡伊普斯维奇附近从国王那里得到了30英亩的土地。这可真搞笑。他会又蹦又跳、吹口哨、放屁。他曾是……
an incompetent uh a posh military officer it's about the war the goon show is about the war but he's hiding in plain sight because he's presenting it as a sort of surrealist bonkers a set of adventures and i think that that's the interesting thing about milligan is is that way before he writes a book about the war way before he tackles it he's dealing with it he's um I couldn't process you say that a lot of this stuff though is more deeply rooted so it goes back to things like the wipers times and the humor and the trenches in the first world war where people also made jokes about the generals and the officers and yeah I mean I don't but I don't know what Milligan knew about that but yes absolutely I mean you know any any war is going to generate
他会跳跃、吹口哨并放屁。他曾是……他要完成一个……而且他没有被授予马刺，而是被编入了国王的侍卫服务中。得到的不是一磅胡椒或一双马刺，他的职责是每天——每年圣诞节在宫廷里表演一套跳跃、吹口哨和放屁的绝技。只有圣诞节那天吗？那他一年中剩下的时间干嘛？萨尔图姆，呃，我不知道。他翘着二郎腿，把肠胃状态调整好。一年中剩下的时间干嘛？萨尔图姆。好吧，我不知道。他翘着二郎腿。
humor or any any you know and and then we of course we then get into arguments about how appropriate any laughing about anything in particular is and and which are questions of taste after all rather than anything else but the wipe yes the wipers time is a fantastic example and also of you know technology being available to people to express their humour. And that's why we know about the Wipers Times, because they wrote it down. And so often humour is a liminal thing that exists in the ether and disappears and is momentary. And so it's very hard to pin down actually what's making people laugh when. Let's dig into that question for a second yeah about taste and what's appropriate so because i mean these are questions we'll get
他把肠胃状态调整好。Saltum siffletum et petum（拉丁语：又跳又吹又放屁）。所以，品味是会改变的。但它们确实变了，因为那是许多人会觉得搞笑的东西。我的意思是，我们现在也在笑。也许这才是人类共通的东西。但是，你知道的，你只需要看一部莎士比亚喜剧，就会纳闷这到底有什么好笑的。有许多希腊喜剧——你知道的，它们在字面意义上就是喜剧，充满了认错人的桥段，并伴随着令人啼笑皆非的后果。我认为，当然，品味会变，如果期待它们一成不变那就太傻了。但是，关于弄臣……是的，还有伊普尔的列兵们，
cancelled we need to be but these are questions not just for for comics they're questions for historians or writers or anybody engaging with the human experience in any way so let's take yeah the the super controversial subject of the of the moment slavery could you imagine um doing something funny or a comedy set i mean it seems so horrific that you kind of recoil instinctively from the idea but could it be done well i don't know it has been done it has been done i yeah well go on well it's been done in in up pompeii which i know is is you know set up 2 000 years ago but frankie howard is a slave and the thing about that is that it's it's very culturally literate because that's the form that roman comedies took there were kind of you
拿他们的军官开玩笑，以及罗马喜剧中的奴隶。这些都是身份地位的问题，是身份地位的问题，没错。这里面真的有很强的危险边缘感，不是吗？因为实际上，危险只有当你身处真正的麻烦时才会显现。所以一个奴隶嘲笑主人，甚至连一个普通士兵嘲笑军官，这都带有真正的风险，这和今天那种靠边缘化博眼球的东西截然不同。或者说，这是一种将权威体制及其运作方式合理化的既定方式。当你审视莎士比亚戏剧中弄臣的概念时，我们会发现，那是某个可以对国王说真话的人，因为他们不知何故获得了某种特许权。这很有趣，因为在罗马传统中——但在罗马共和传统中——人们对怪胎和奇人更感兴趣，而不是一个拥有弄臣、拥有傻子的国王。而真正有趣的是，弄臣和傻子这一概念的发展历程是：傻子唯一的庇护人就是国王。因此，他在某种程度上脱离了其他形式的
know the the sassy slave who provides the commentary on the masters. And when did that run? 70s, I think. 70s, yeah. And it was regarded, I guess, as completely unproblematic. But that's because it's a different kind of slavery, isn't it? Would it be now? Yeah, but people are much more sensitive now about slavery, I think, than they were. And I wonder whether having your kind of lead comic actor as a slave,
庇护，所以他能够说出真相。你知道的，如果你是亨利八世的傻子，诺福克公爵（Duke of Norfolk）是无法通过行贿来对付你的。你对国王直言不讳。那么在这个例子中，真相到底是什么呢？在英国——并且在拥有国王的社会中普遍存在——有两种类型的傻子。这在很大程度上与基督教神学有关。你又要……你知道的，别鼓励他，告诉他……看，他从呆滞中清醒过来了。太好了，汤姆刚才基本上睡着了。这在很大程度上归结于天真无邪和神学上的纯真这一概念。如果你是一个用我们现在的话说可能有学习障碍的人，如果你是一个无法理解现实世界是如何运作的人——所以在中世纪早期直至都铎王朝时期，
would that be as unproblematic as it was in the 70s? I don't know. I mean, you'd probably have a better sense of that than... Well, I mean, I wouldn't take it to BBC One right now. No. No. Maybe Channel 5. The thing is, well, the thing is, is that these are, you know,
你在上帝面前被视为天真无邪，因为你不知道发生了什么。这就演变成了两种傻子的概念。一种是“天生傻子”（naturals），即那些患有某种精神障碍的人。另一种是“后天傻子”（artificials），即那些假装有某种精神障碍的人。而那些最终被砍掉脑袋的正是“后天傻子”，因为到头来，他们在上帝、国王或庇护人面前没有任何辩护的余地。因为如果他们说了出格的话，所有人都会说：“我们非常清楚你并不单纯，你是在装傻，这只是你的把戏。”这些人往往会惹上麻烦，而真正的天生单纯的人则往往不会。你知道的，看看威廉·萨默（Will Somers），他是亨利八世的傻子。
I mean, I think what's very interesting is is these are questions of taste after all. And tastes change. And I mean, there is this forever argument. I mean, it's interesting that you're framing like this because because 10 years ago there was an argument that comedy is about pushing boundaries. You know, you've got to be edgy you've got to break boundaries and you know and and those arguments were wheeled out in defense um uh of of uh people during the during the russell brown jonathan ross saxgate debacle that that argument was wheeled out by quite serious people comedy's job is to push the boundaries but well every now and again somebody go not those boundaries yeah yeah yeah but not those boundaries. Yeah. Yeah, but not those boundaries, thank you very much. We'd rather not.
他后来也出现在爱德华六世的宫廷里。他一直延续到了玛丽女王的宫廷，我想他甚至活到了伊丽莎白女王时期。现在，如果我们回顾《1066和这一切》中关于那一时期都铎王朝政治的版本，你知道的，如果你跟亨利八世混得好，你就不能跟……如果你跟爱德华混得好，你就不能跟玛丽混得好，你根本不可能像那样成为都铎英格兰宫廷里一个安稳无事的存在。但他却一路畅通无阻，因为他天真无邪，因为他发挥着某种功能。你会发现，这里还有一条模糊的界限，基本上就是有些人的身份是……他发挥着某种功能。你会发现。你会发现。这里还有一条模糊的界限，基本上就是有些人是王室的陪伴者，他们很明显患有某种精神障碍，因为他们没有被权力和宫廷等种种负担所困扰。你就可以把他们当作哥们儿，而弄臣就占据了这样一个非常有趣、奇特而又边缘的空间。纵观英国宫廷记录，你会发现他们都在工资名单上。他们独自吃饭，不跟弄臣——他们与弄臣或
And, you know, Milligan, of course. Milligan spent ten years inserting rude names into the Goon Show and having them removed if the censor at the BBC spotted them. And, you know, characters called Hugh Hampton, Hugh Hampton, Hampton Wick, it's a bloke with a big dick. You know, he spent a great deal of time doing that because those were the boundaries and those were the boundaries he was kicking up against
艺人是分开的。艺人最初是仆人，后来意识到，如果你是一个会弹琵琶的仆人，你的价值就会比不会弹琵琶的仆人大一倍。于是你最终得到了这种奇特的宫廷追随者大杂烩，而核心就是弄臣。在16世纪，有一个他们破圈而出的时刻，当
at the time, you know. And I think so much of this, there's a tangle between what are basically, they're questions of taste, but they get elevated to questions of principle. And very often that can be that that's that could be quite a tricky uh set of waters to navigate though what i will say is as a as a practicing comedian these things aren't half as don't or don't strike me as half as urgent or
戏剧出现时，基本上存在一个技术时刻——戏剧本身确立为了一种技术形式，而弄臣开始……基本上存在一个技术时刻——戏剧本身确立为了一种技术形式，而弄臣开始两者兼顾。比如理查德·塔尔顿（Richard Tarleton），他不仅是宫廷弄臣，还是职业弄臣以及女王御用演员之一。他基本上宣告了李尔王式的弄臣概念的终结，并开启了向喜剧演员、彻头彻尾的喜剧演员的转变。他在全国巡演，
worrying as they do if i read an article about them you know that uh that there's there's people just getting on with it and then there's the stuff being written about it which after all is the liminal world i'm talking here's a question for you al about you talk about taste changing and the boundaries changing now that would seem to imply that what we think is funny changes does it well of course it does um uh for instance uh there's a fool uh from called roland le petator who was on the payroll of henry ii right and he received 30 acres from the king near ipswich in suffolk for his farting act that's funny he would leap whistle and fart um he was uh he was to make an and instead of being given uh his spurs,
作为一名巡回喜剧演员享有国际声誉，同时也是12位女王御用演员之一。所以这就出现了一种……喜剧演员曾经依赖王室庇护，然后转变为拥有公众选区和表演对象的群体。而与此同时，一直有一种观念认为他们在说真话，并且他们被允许说真话，因为他们不懂现实世界和神学。可以说，他们不会因为自己所说的话而下地狱。
he was enrolled into the King's sergeant service. And instead of being given a pound of pepper or a pair of spurs, his duty was to do every day, every Christmas day at court, a leap, a whistle and a fart act. Only at Christmas Day? What did he do the rest of the year? Sultum, well, I don't know. He had his feet up, got his bowels ready. Sult the rest of the year? Saltum. Well, I don't know. He had his feet up.
好吧，我认为这是一个绝妙的概念，可以借此来探讨这种边缘性和地狱。但在你这么做之前，有一个很棒的故事。这可以一直追溯到公元前209年至27年的秦朝第二位皇帝。他宣布要给万里长城刷上一层漆。对。故事说，朝臣们面面相觑。谁去告诉他？不，我才不告诉他这是个多糟糕的主意呢。这时，有个叫“歪杆”（Twisty Pole）的傻子站出来说：“这真是个绝妙的主意，老板。但问题是，我们该怎么让它干透呢？”
He got his bowels ready. Saltum siffletum et petum. And so tastes change. But they have, though, because that's something that a lot of people would find funny. I mean, we're laughing about it now. Maybe that's the universal thing. But, you know, I mean, you only have to look at a Shakespeare comedy to wonder what on earth is funny about this. There's a lot of Greek comedies, you know, which, after all, are comedy in the literal sense,
“我们得在它上面建一个巨大无比的烘干房。”于是皇帝说：“哦，对啊，理所当然。这主意太棒了。”这样，朝臣们就不用当面顶撞他了。这就是傻子的用处。你认为过去人们总是把傻子当作这样一种安全阀吗？多米尼克。是的。
where there's a mistaken identity and with hilarious consequences. And I think, of course, tastes change. It'd be silly to expect them not to but how on the um the the jester yes and indeed the um the the the privates in in um at ypres yeah joking about their officers and the slave in roman comedy yeah well these are status positions of these are questions of status yeah absolutely there's real edge there isn't there because actually the edge comes if you're in real trouble so a slave laughing at the master um you know even even a private soldier laughing at the officer there's real jeopardy there in a way that there wouldn't be today
多米尼克，我们得休息一下了。我刚才简直是在你背上横冲直撞。不，我们刚才提到了万里长城的笑话。这简直是进广告的完美时机。好吧，那就去吧，那就去吧。去休息吧，去休息吧。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），
with an edgy or what it is is or what it is is is or not or what it is is it's a priced in way of of of accommodating your systems of authority and how they work and when you look at the i mean if you look at the shakespearean idea of the gesture that we have that there's a someone who can speak truth to the king because because they get granted license somehow and that it's interesting because in in roman tradition because but roman republican tradition they're much more interested in freaks and things rather than rather than a king who has a jester a king who has a fool and what's what's really interesting is the way the jester and the fool thing develops is it's it is the the only patron that the fool has is the king so he's in mute he's removed divorced from other forms of
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我们正在讨论喜剧和喜剧演员。在中场休息之前，我……我打断了别人，这挺粗鲁的，他当时有个什么问题来着。多米尼克，你的问题是什么？所以我的问题
patronage so he can speak the truth so you know that if you're Henry VIII's fool the Duke of Norfolk can't get at you by bribing you you speak truth to the king and what is truth in this instance well there's two types of fool um that that we see in england and it's kind of universal in in societies with kings two types of fool and it's a lot to do with christian theology and you're going to so you know don't encourage him out tell him he emerges from his torpor oh great tom was asleep basically well and a lot of it what it it comes down to is the idea of innocence and theological innocence. And if you are someone who has what we would probably call a learning disability now, if you're someone who can't get to the grips with the world as it's seen, so theology in the early Middle Ages and through to the Tudors,
是关于作为安全阀的弄臣，阿尔。阿尔刚才谈到了作为安全阀的弄臣。所以他们处于一个其他人都不具备的位置。朝臣们是否有意利用他们来传达那些无法言说的话呢？哦，是的，你会拥有你自己的……我的意思是，关于威廉·萨默的一个有趣之处在于，他是从别的公爵那里被挖角过来的——在威廉·萨默之前的那个傻子是一个叫塞克斯顿（Sexton）的人，他是托马斯·沃尔西（Thomas Wolsey）的傻子。当沃尔西失势时，他留下来安度晚年的条件之一，就是交出他的傻子——他把塞克斯顿交给了国王，而国王对此并不高兴。
you're regarded as innocent before God because you don't know what's going on. And this turns into the idea of the two types of fool. There's naturals who are people who have some sort of mental disability. And then there's artificials who are people who pretend to have some sort of disability. And it's the it's the the ones who get their heads chopped off are the artificials because in the end they have no defense before god or their king or their patron because that if they speak out of line everyone goes we we know perfectly well you're not innocent you're putting it on this is your this is your act and they're the guys who get into trouble whereas the innocents tend not to you know you look at look at Will Will Summer, who was Henry VIII's fool.
后来，随着塞克斯顿变老，有人说：“某个府邸里有个绝妙的傻子，国王应该把他弄来。”所以这里存在一个流通圈子，所有人都在这么做。但是，我的意思是，这是一个非常艰难的……为了回答你的问题，正如你刚才所提出的那样，作为一个安全阀，这绝对是一个根深蒂固的观念，至少在西欧文化中绝对如此。伊拉斯谟（Erasmus）曾说，正如他对文艺复兴时期弄臣的评价那样，他们可以说出真相，甚至是公开的侮辱，并且会被带着愉悦的心情聆听。事实上，那些会让一个聪明人付出生命代价的话语，从一个小丑口中说出来时却出奇地令人愉快。因为如果真相能够做到不得罪人，它就确实拥有取悦人的力量。但这是神灵只赐予傻子的特权。太棒了。所以，阿尔，既然汤姆刚才
He's also then he's then in the court of Edward VI. He goes through to Queen Mary's court as well and I think lives until Elizabeth. Now, if we look at the 1066 and all that version of the politic Tudor politics at that time, you know, if you're in with Henry VIII, you can't be in with, you time if you're in with Henry VIII you can't be in with if you're in with Edward you can't be in with Mary, you can't possibly be in a manageable presence within the court of Tudor England like that but he runs
那么粗鲁，我要问第二个问题。对，紧接着刚才的话题再深入一点。他比他兄弟更具侵略性，他比他兄弟更有进取心。我打断了……好吧，这很有趣。不，老实说，我们现在进入战略层面了。我不这么觉得。好吧，听着。我刚才想到的一件事是，几年前，乔纳森·科（Jonathan Coe）在《伦敦书评》（London Review of Books）上发表了一篇文章，谈到了讽刺。
right through because he's innocent and because he performs a function and you see that there's also a blurred line where basically you have people who are He performs a function. And you see. You see. There's also a blurred line where basically you have people who are companions to royalty who quite clearly have some sort of mental disability because they're not troubled by the burdens of power and the court and all that sort of stuff. And you can just have have them as your pal and and fools occupy this really interesting strange liminal space and and all the way through english court records you see them on the payroll they eat on their own they don't eat with the jesters that they're separate from the jest or
他谈到英国傻笑着沉入大海，这就是那种我们被讽刺淹没的意象。但基本上，讽刺……现在，小说家乔纳森·科不把讽刺看作是一种安全阀，也不认为它是一件健康的事，反而认为它是一件不健康的事。我们太忙于沾沾自喜并自我嘲笑了。他认为我们对讽刺的痴迷催生了鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）、英国脱欧和糟糕的政府。
for the minstrels rather and minstrels start out as servants and then realize that that they're if you're a servant who can play the lute you're worth twice a servant who can't and so you end up with this sort of weird hodgepodge of court followers and at the heart of it is the fool and there's the moment in the 16th century where they sort of break out and when the
对于游吟诗人来说，他们最初是仆人，后来发现，如果你是一个会弹琵琶的仆人，你的价值就会翻倍，于是这就变成了一种奇特的宫廷随从大杂烩，而核心就是弄臣。在16世纪，他们有过一次爆发，当时
theatre comes along and there's essentially a technological moment where theatre establishes itself as a piece of technology and fools start There's essentially a technological moment where theatre establishes itself as a piece of technology. And fools start doing both. And there's Richard Tarleton, who is not only a court fool, but also a professional fool and one of the Queen's men. And he's basically the beginning of the end of the idea of the Lear-like fool and the transition into comedian, full-on comedian. And he tours the country.
戏剧兴起，本质上这是一个技术的时刻，戏剧作为一项技术确立了自身的地位，而弄臣开始两栖发展。比如理查德·塔尔顿，他不仅是宫廷弄臣，还是职业弄臣以及女王卫队成员。他基本上是“李尔王式弄臣”这一概念走向终结的开端，并过渡到了喜剧演员，完全意义上的喜剧演员。他在全国巡演。
He has an international reputation as a touring comic and is also one of the 12 Queen's Men. And there's this... So comedians relied on royal patronage and then it flips into they have a public constituency and people to play to. And all the while, there is this idea that they're telling the truth and they're allowed to tell the truth because they don't understand the real world and theology. They're not going to go to hell for what they say, as it were.
他作为巡回喜剧演员享有国际声誉，也是12位女王卫队成员之一。这就是……因此喜剧演员依赖皇室资助，随后转变为拥有公众选民和可以表演的观众。与此同时，一直有一种观念认为他们在说真话，并且被允许说真话，因为他们不懂现实世界和神学。他们不会因为自己所说的话而下地狱。
Well, I think that's a brilliant notion on which to take the liminality, the hell. But before you do, there's a great story. And this goes all the way back to the second emperor, Quinn, in 209 to 27 BC. He announces that he's going to lacquer the Great Wall of China. Right. And the story is the court is all looking at each other. You're going to tell him, no, I'm not going to tell him what a terrible idea. And there's a fool called Twisty Pole who steps forward and says, that's a brilliant idea, boss. But the problem is, is how are we going to get it to dry?
嗯，我认为这是一个绝妙的概念，可以借此来探讨边缘性和地狱。但在你这么做之前，有一个很棒的故事。这要追溯到公元前209年至207年的秦朝二世。他宣布要给万里长城刷漆。没错。故事说的是，朝臣们面面相觑。你要去告诉他？不，我才不要告诉他这是多么糟糕的主意。这时，一个叫滑竿的弄臣站出来说，老板，这是个绝妙的主意。但问题是，我们怎么让它干透呢？
We're going to have to build a great big drying house over it. And the emperor goes, oh, yeah, obviously. What a terrible idea. And so the courtiers don't have to confront him. And that's what the fool is for. And do you think that was used, the fool was always used as that sort of safety valve? Dominic. Yeah.
我们得在它上面建一个巨大无比的烘干房。于是皇帝说，哦，对啊，当然。真是个糟糕的主意。这样朝臣们就不必去顶撞他了。这就是弄臣的作用。你觉得这曾被用过吗，弄臣一直被用作那种安全阀吗？多米尼克。是的。
Dominic, we've got to have a break. I just was riding roughshod over your back. No, we've had a great wall of China, Jake. That is just riding roughshod over your back. No, no, we've had a great wall of China, Jake. That is the perfect note on which to go for a break. Oh, go on then, go on then. Have your break, have your break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman,
多米尼克，我们得休息一下。我刚才有点太粗暴地打断你了。不，我们提到了万里长城，杰克。这简直就是粗暴地打断了。不，不，我们提到了万里长城，杰克。这正是去休息的完美时机。哦，那就去吧，去吧。去休息吧，去休息吧。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，
and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history we're talking comedy comics um before the break i uh i cut down it was rude he had some question or other dominic what was your question so my question
我们共同主持《娱乐滑铁卢》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史滑铁卢》（The Rest Is History），我们正在讨论喜剧、喜剧演员，呃，在休息之前，我，呃，打断了，这有点粗鲁，他有一些这样那样的问题。多米尼克，你的问题是什么？所以我的问题
was about fools as safety valves al Al was talking about fools as this. So they're in a position that nobody else is in. And do the courtiers knowingly use them to deliver the undeliverable message and so on? Well, yes, you'd have your own. I mean, one of the interesting things about Will Summer is he's poached from some other duke you know uh uh after the fool that precedes will summer um is a guy called sexton that that was thomas woolsey's fool and when woolsey falls from grace one of the one of the conditions that he's left left uh to live out his remaining days in peace is that he hands over his fool so he surrenders sexton to the king who's not happy about it
是关于作为安全阀的弄臣，阿尔刚才在谈论弄臣时就提到了这一点。所以他们处于一个其他人都不具备的位置。朝臣们是否会明知故问地利用他们来传递无法传达的信息等等？嗯，是的，你会拥有自己的弄臣。我的意思是，关于威尔·萨默的一个有趣之处在于，他是从其他公爵那里挖角过来的，你知道的，呃，在威尔·萨默之前的那个弄臣是一个叫塞克斯顿的人，那是托马斯·沃尔西的弄臣。当沃尔西失势时，他得以安度余生的条件之一就是交出他的弄臣，也就是把塞克斯顿交还给国王，而国王对此并不高兴。
and then eventually as sexton gets old someone says there's this great fool um in this household you should you should the king should have him so there's a circuit of it everyone's doing this but but i mean this is a very hard i mean in answer your question it's a very that you posited just before as a safety valve it's a hardwired idea this in in certainly it definitely deep in western european culture erasmus says they can as he says of renaissance fools they can speak truth and even open insults and be heard with positive pleasure indeed the words that would cost a wise man his life are surprisingly enjoyable when uttered by a clown for truth has a genuine power to please if it manages not to give offense but this is something the gods have granted only to fools nice so al since tom was
然后最终，当塞克斯顿老去时，有人说在这个府邸里有个很棒的弄臣，你应该，国王应该拥有他。所以这形成了一个循环，大家都在这么做。但是，我的意思是一个非常困难的问题——我是说为了回答你刚才提出的关于安全阀的问题——这在西欧文化中是一个根深蒂固的概念，伊拉斯谟说过，文艺复兴时期的弄臣可以说真话甚至是公开的侮辱，并被人们以积极的愉悦所接受，事实上，那些会让智者付出生命代价的话语，从一个小丑口中说出来时却出奇地令人愉快，因为真言确实有着取悦人心的天然力量，只要它设法不引起冒犯，但这是神只赋予弄臣的特权。太好了，既然汤姆那么
so rude i'm going to ask a second question yeah and this is to and this is to follow up on that a little bit he's much more he's much more pushy than his brother is he he's more pushy than his brother i cut well that's interesting no i'm not honestly getting onto the strategic level here i don't think so all right listen now something that came up in my mind while you were just talking was a few years ago, Jonathan Coe wrote an essay in the London Review of Books talking about satire. And he was talking about Britain sinking, giggling into the sea, which is this sort of, this image of us awash with satire.
粗鲁，我要问第二个问题。是的，这也是为了跟进刚才的话题。他比他哥哥更有进取心。他比他哥哥更有进取心。我打断了——好吧，这很有趣。不，老实说，我不是在谈论战略层面。我不这么认为。好吧，听着，刚才你在说话的时候我脑子里冒出来的一件事是，几年前，乔纳森·科（Jonathan Coe）在《伦敦书评》上写了一篇关于讽刺的文章。他谈到英国一边咯咯笑着一边沉入海底，这就是那种被讽刺淹没的意象。
But basically, satire being... Now, Jonathan Coe, the novelist Jonathan Coe, thought of satire not as a safety valve and not as a healthy thing, but as an unhealthy thing. That we were too busy being slightly complacent and laughing at ourselves. He thought our obsession with satire had produced Boris Johnson and Brexit and bad government
但基本上，讽刺变成了……现在，小说家乔纳森·科并不认为讽刺是一种安全阀，也不认为是一件健康的事情，而是一件不健康的事情。我们太忙于沾沾自喜和自我嘲笑了。他认为我们对讽刺的痴迷催生了鲍里斯·约翰逊、英国脱欧以及糟糕的政府。
and that we should be as a society more angry and we and things like have i got news for you he thought as positively bad for us what's your take that's interesting well i think that's interesting because i think um one of the big problems with with with the s word has been a a failure to define terms when people talk about it you'll very often see i mean we talked about the goon show earlier i would contend that that's a satire that the goon the goon show is satire surrealist satire but it's satire but but milligan being a blue collar irishman um uh at the time no one saw it for what it was and then of course you get the satire boom in the 60s,
我们作为一个社会应该更愤怒，他认为像《你有看新闻吗》这类节目对我们极为有害，你的看法呢？这很有意思，嗯，我觉得这很有意思，因为我认为，嗯，关于这个“讽刺”这个词（s开头的词），最大的问题之一就是一直未能给术语下定义，当人们谈论它时，你经常会看到——我们刚才聊过《呆子秀》，我会认为那是一种讽刺，呆子秀是讽刺，超现实主义的讽刺，但它是讽刺，然而，米利根作为一名蓝领爱尔兰人，嗯，当时没有人看出它的本质，然后当然，你在60年代迎来了讽刺热潮，
which is called that with a capital S. And because they're all people who should have ended up in the foreign office or in academia, it's seen as some sort of extraordinary break, an incredible moment that we all live in the shadow of forever since. And I think the problem with that narrative is that is that jokes about the news and jokes about politicians aren't necessarily satire you know tom sharp i thought i think wrote satire um but no one would no one
这个词的首字母是大写的S。而且因为他们都是本该进入外交部或学术界的人，它被视为某种非凡的突破，是我们从那以后永远生活在其阴影之下的一个不可思议的时刻。我认为这种叙事的问题在于，关于新闻的笑话和关于政治家的笑话不一定就是讽刺，你知道，汤姆·夏普，我曾经认为，我认为他写过讽刺作品，但没有人会，没有人
would include him in a in a sort of satirical lineage now they would talk about have i got news for you as satire and i don't think it is i think it's a topical news program topical news comedy program i don't think it's satirical because it does it does it prick at our underlying assumptions does it say is it saying you get the politicians you deserve or is it the part of the process of delivering us the politicians we deserve which i I think is what Jonathan means. I think I think, you know, I think what he means is there's too much levity rather than too much satire. It's how I how I how I'd read that because that, you know, I mean, one of the one of the one of the problems in broadcasting, of course, because I mean, I've just written on the last the last series of spitting image and uh you know the interesting about interesting thing about spitting images we all have very rosy uh tinted spectacle view of it
会把他归入某种讽刺的传承中，现在他们会把《你有看新闻吗》称为讽刺，而我不认为它是，我认为它是一个时政新闻节目，时政新闻喜剧节目，我不认为它是讽刺，因为它并没有，它戳中了我们的基本假设吗？它是在说“你得到了你应得的政客”，还是它正是为我们输送我们应得的政客这一进程的一部分？我想这正是乔纳森的意思。我想，我想，你知道，我想他的意思是我们太轻浮了，而不是讽刺太多。这就是我，这就是我，这就是我对这句话的解读，因为，你知道，我的意思是，广播界的其中一个，其中一个，其中一个问题，当然，因为我的意思是，我刚刚写了最后一季的《形象大战》，然后，你知道，关于《形象大战》有趣的地方在于，我们对它都有非常玫瑰色、戴着玫瑰色眼镜的看法，
when it first started and you watch the first series and it's all over the shop because it's a brand new program in an in a in a literally a new medium of trying to do this through puppetry and impressions and all that and they And they just about get away with it and they do it on shock, you know, because it's so extraordinary to see. And maybe, I mean, after all, satire, it's juvenile, isn't it, Tom? And the thing about juvenile is it's all been censored
当它刚开始播的时候，你看了第一季，它到处都是漏洞，因为这是一个全新的节目，在一个，在一个，字面意义上的新媒介中，试图通过木偶戏和模仿秀来做到这一点，诸如此类，而他们，他们勉强做到了，他们靠的是震惊，你知道，因为看到这一幕太不寻常了。也许，我的意思是，毕竟，讽刺，它是幼稚的，对吧，汤姆？而说到幼稚，它已经被全面审查了，
because it's filth, isn't it? Well, juvenile is, yeah, I mean, incredibly filthy. What do we mean by, I mean, and this brings me back to my, what do we mean by satire, you know? Because in juvenile cases, it's lots of really filthy, filthy jokes, isn't it? And, well, they're not even jokes. And very, very bitter, very, very bitter commentary. I mean, juvenile would definitely get cancelled now because he detests immigrants.
因为那是下流的东西，不是吗？嗯，幼稚是，是的，我的意思是，极其下流。我们是什么意思，我的意思是，这让我想起了我的，我们说的讽刺是什么意思，你知道？因为在少年犯的案例中，有很多非常下流、非常下流的笑话，不是吗？而且，它们甚至都不是笑话。还有非常非常刻薄、非常非常刻薄的评论。我的意思是，少年犯现在绝对会被取消，因为他痛恨移民。
He's always going on about how awful immigrants are. he he detests immigrants he's always going on about how awful immigrants are yeah um and he goes he he hates women he's misogynist i mean in almost every he basically hates everyone and everything yeah and and i think this you know would would it's kind of tough it's tough to read um certainly for our sensibilities now yeah and i think i know what i think think I know what Jonathan's driving at, but I think you've got to ask yourself whether things are satire or not. I mean, I think Jonathan's books are satire
他总是喋喋不休地说移民有多糟糕。他，他痛恨移民，他总是喋喋不休地说移民有多糟糕，是的，嗯，他去，他讨厌女人，他厌女，我的意思是，在几乎每一个，他基本上恨所有人和所有事，是的，而且，我认为这，你知道，会，这有点难，这很难读，尤其是对我们现在的敏感神经来说，是的，而且我想我知道，我想我知道乔纳森想表达什么，但我认为你必须问问自己，这些事情到底是不是讽刺。我的意思是，我认为乔纳森的书是讽刺，
in a way that Have I Got News For You probably isn't. Isn't it also the fact that the giggling, sinking giggling into the sea, isn't that also Peter Cook? Yeah. the fact that the the giggling sinking giggling into the sea isn't that also um peter cook and and the um you were talking about how um uh the goon show is a satire on on the second world war yeah so famously is beyond the fringe with the you know we need an actor gesture at this point a futile gesture and all that and and that presumably dominic you'd know but better than anyone i mean that was genuinely shocking when someone did, when they did that.
而《你有看新闻吗》可能不是。难道这也关乎那种咯咯笑着、一边咯咯笑着一边沉入大海的情节吗，难道那不也是彼得·库克吗？是的。事实上，咯咯笑着、一边咯咯笑着一边沉入海底，难道那不也是，嗯，彼得·库克，还有，嗯，你刚才在讲，嗯，嗯，《呆子秀》是对第二次世界大卷的讽刺，对吧？所以同样出名的还有《超越边缘》，里面有那种“我们需要一个演员在这个时候做个手势，一个徒劳的手势”之类的，而多米尼克，你大概比任何人都清楚，当有人做出那种举动时，那真的是相当令人震惊。
Was it or not? I'm always unsure about this. I think some people were shocked, just like some people were shocked by that was the week that was. But it's a sort of a performance of being shocked, I think, often. Well, I agree. I agree with that. I think that, because after all, very often humour and its locus is really, really important.
是这样吗？我对此一直不太确定。我觉得有些人感到震惊，就像有些人对《那是本周的那一周》感到震惊一样。但我觉得这通常只是一种假装震惊的表演。嗯，我同意。我同意这一点。我认为，因为毕竟，幽默及其语境往往，真的是非常非常重要的。
Jimmy Carr, a while ago, I mean, it's quite a while back, this, he got into trouble for telling a joke that he had heard at Headley Court. And Headley Court was the rehab place for injured British soldiers. And there were lots of guys from Afghanistan there. And a bloke there said to him, you know, whatever else happens, we're going to get a great Paralympic team for 2012 out of this, aren't we? Ha ha ha. Right.
吉米·卡尔，不久前，我的意思是，这已经是好一阵子前的事了，他因为讲了一个在海德利法院听来的笑话而惹上了麻烦。海德利法院是英国受伤士兵的康复中心。那里有很多来自阿富汗的小伙子。那里的一个家伙对他说，你知道，不管发生什么，我们都会从这次经历中为2012年凑出一支棒极了的残奥代表队，对吧？哈哈哈哈。对。
And that was an injured soldier's joke told in an injured soldier setting. And Jimmy, Jimmy lobbed it in as a sort of as a as a as a shocking bar. But he got into trouble for it. But that's that's that's because he really he moved the locus of the joke. You know, he tried to, you know, take a seedling seedling and plant it in the wrong garden, if you see what I mean. And I think that we need a futile gesture from you, Perkins, is probably, if you were an airman during the war, they were probably all saying that to each other, that that's the black humour that informs extremely difficult situations. You know, squatty humour is extremely dark. It's the fact that they were doing it in an unexpected environment. And after all, they're nice chaps who really ought to have been in the foreign office and been Oxford dons. It's as much to do with the shock of the people deciding to behave like this, deciding to joke about this rather than the jokes themselves.
那是受伤士兵的笑话，是在受伤士兵的环境中讲的。而吉米，吉米把它当作一种，一种，一种令人震惊的段子抛了出来。但他因此惹上了麻烦。但那是因为他真的，他改变了笑话的语境。你知道，他试图，你知道，把一株幼苗，一株幼苗拔起来，种错了花园，如果你明白我的意思的话。我认为我们需要你来个徒劳的手势，帕金斯，可能如果你是战争期间的一名飞行员，他们大概都在互相这么说，那是那种贯穿极度困难处境的黑色幽默。你知道，下士的幽默是极其黑暗的。关键在于他们在意料之外的环境中这么做。而且毕竟，他们都是些本该去外交部当牛津大学导师的好小伙子。这很大程度上与人们决定这样做的震惊有关，决定拿这个开玩笑，而不是笑话本身。
And, you know, so much so much framing and context colours people's reactions as much as the material very often the material goes by the by i mean ricky ricka gervais says you know people often hear the words in a joke they don't think for a moment what the joke's about they they just hear the things in it and don't think what's this actually about and i think you know there's a famous famous account of a guy when the when when beyond Fringe transferred to New York who stood up at the end of one sketch and said, you're a bunch of absolute rotters, and then sat back down again and enjoyed the rest of the show.
而且，你知道，太多的框架和语境往往会左右人们的反应，材料本身往往会被抛诸脑后，我的意思是瑞奇·热维斯说过，你知道，人们经常听到笑话里的词，他们不会花哪怕一秒钟去想想这个笑话到底是关于什么的，他们只是听到了里面的东西，却不去想这到底是在说什么，而且我认为，你知道，有一个著名的，著名的故事，当《超越边缘》转战纽约时，有个家伙在其中一个短剧结束时站起来说，你们这群绝对的混蛋，然后又坐下，继续欣赏剩下的演出。
So outrageous performance, it's as performative as laughing sometimes. Being in on a joke or being out on a joke, they're as important as each other. What's your take on that? We've got jokes. Hold on, hold on. I want to ask my question, don't do this again okay no no we we i've got firm instructions that we've got to do some of the questions from the listeners
所以这是离谱的表演，它有时和笑话一样具有表演性。懂梗还是不懂梗，它们彼此同样重要。你对这个有什么看法？我们有笑话。等等，等等。我想问我的问题，别再这样了，好吧，不，不，我们，我有严格的指令，我们必须回答一些听众的问题，
so dominic you're just you're just so domineering i know this all the time i'm just bullying i bulldog with his question the thing is i can't stop talking and tom can never get a word in edgeways i've actually got a message from the producer saying possible i've actually got a message from the producer saying... It's just impossible. I've actually got a message from the producer, Tom, saying ask your question. So I'm going to ask my question. My question is this. God's sake, and now I'm being undermined by the producer.
所以多米尼克，你实在是太霸道了。我知道，我一直这样。我只是在霸凌，我像斗牛犬一样揪着他的问题不放。问题是我停不下来，而汤姆根本插不上话。我其实收到了一条制作人的消息，说可能，我其实收到了一条制作人的消息，说……这简直不可能。我其实收到了一条制作人的消息，汤姆，说“问你的问题”。所以我现在要问我的问题。我的问题是这个。天哪，现在我竟然被制作人拆台了。
Yeah, I've been waiting for this moment. You see what I have to put up with, Al? Did this happen on the other podcast? No. They gave up. They gave up trying to control us long ago. It's too late now. Go on, Dominic. Give us your fascinating question. So it's a good question. It's too late now. Go on, Dominic. Give us your fascinating question.
对，我一直在等这一刻。你看我得忍受什么，阿尔？另一个播客也是这样吗？没有。他们放弃了。他们很久以前就放弃控制我们了。现在太晚了。说吧，多米尼克。快问出你那个迷人的问题。所以这是一个好问题。现在太晚了。说吧，多米尼克。快问出你那个迷人的问题。
So it's a good question. It's a question about comedy that was once funny and is now dated. Should it be, as it were, cancelled? I.e., should it be preceded by a warning or should it just simply not be broadcast? And since you're a big Spike Milligan fan, Spike Milligan is a very good example of this because, of course, he did routines
所以这是一个好问题。这是一个关于喜剧的问题：曾经搞笑、现在却过时了的喜剧。它应该，可以说是被“取消”吗？也就是说，它应该在播出前加上警告，还是干脆不应该播出？既然你是斯派克·米利根的超级粉丝，斯派克·米利根就是一个很好的例子，因为当然，他在20世纪70年代表演过一些常规节目，
or he played characters in the 1970s, Blacking Up, for example, that now, if the BBC broadcast it, there would be howls of outrage. So how should broadcasters and people like that deal with this sort of issue? Well, I mean, what they could do is commission some new stuff so they don't need to fill their schedules with boring old things from the old days. I mean, I think is, you know, as someone actually as someone actually concerned with making comedy that that strikes me as the solution to the problem. And after all, jokes about now, I mean, Barry Humphrey's famously says the moment you die, you're no longer funny. You know that you're you that you live the comedy lives right
或者扮演过一些角色，比如涂黑脸化妆，如果在今天，如果BBC播出这些，必然会引发轩然大波。那么，广播公司和类似的人应该如何处理这种问题呢？嗯，我的意思是，他们可以做的是委托创作一些新东西，这样他们就不需要用过去那些无聊的旧东西来填满节目表了。我的意思是，作为一个真正致力于创作能引起共鸣的喜剧的人，我认为这就是解决问题的办法。毕竟，关于当下的笑话，我的意思是，巴里·汉弗里斯曾有句名言：你死的那个瞬间，你就不再好笑了。你知道的，你，喜剧只活在
in the present moment and of course it's not funny if it's from 30 years ago 40 years ago of course not because aside from the aside from those racist aspects all the frames of reference will be um uh shot anyway you know uh and i think it's remarkable when things are funny from the olden days. But lots of things are funny. I mean, I watched Fawlty Towers with my son the other day, and he found that funny. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's pretty funny, but there's been a bit of that sliced out because people... Yeah, you're right, you're right, the major.
当下这一刻，当然，如果是30年前、40年前的笑话，那就不好笑了，当然不好笑，因为除了那些种族主义的方面，所有的参考框架无论如何都已经是，嗯，过时的了，你知道，嗯，而且我认为，当旧时代的那些东西依然好笑时，这真的很了不起。但很多东西都好笑。我的意思是，我前几天和儿子一起看了《费尔蒂旅馆》，他觉得很好笑。对，对，对，那个挺好笑的，不过里面有一小段被剪掉了，因为人们……对，你说得对，你说得对，少校的那段。
Again, have done the thing where they miss the subject of the joke and they hear the words, and sometimes that's enough for people that they, no, I'm sorry, can't be around that, we can't joke about that in that way anymore. OK, we have a question from the brilliantly named keir hardly you like that that's very good that's the funniest thing on this program so far entirely functional love the show love the show and also love we have ways of making you talk despite my very limited understanding of military history so that's for you al well um and he says are some things taboo because of our prevailing attitudes now so that's what we've been talking about but what i wonder is is there a kind of churn that certain things are always held to be
同样，人们没有抓住笑话的主旨，只是听到了其中的词汇，有时候这就足够让人们说，不，对不起，我无法接受这个，我们不能再那样拿这个开玩笑了。好的，我们有一个来自名字非常棒的“基尔·哈德利”的提问，你喜欢这个吗？这很好，这是这档节目到目前为止最搞笑的部分了，完全实用，超级喜欢这个节目，也超级喜欢《审讯室》，尽管我对军事历史的了解非常有限，所以这是给你的，阿尔。嗯，然后他说，由于我们现在普遍的态度，某些事物是否成了禁忌？所以这就是我们一直在谈论的，但我想知道的是，是否存在这样一种循环，即某些事物永远被视为
sacred or unsayable or whatever and that that then kind of automatically generates comedy because the moment you're not it's kind of like getting the giggles at a funeral or something. Not being allowed to laugh about something kind of almost automatically makes you want to laugh about it. Well, yes. That's a kind of part of the cycle of what goes on. Absolutely. You know, and after all, after all, saying the unsayable is an awfully good way of claiming you're saying the unsayable is an awfully good way of selling tickets or making a name for yourself. Let's not forget that comedy, like any other art form,
神圣不可侵犯的，或是不能说之类，而这种设定随后又会自动引发喜剧效果？因为当你不能这么做时，那种感觉就像是在葬礼上突然忍不住咯咯笑一样。不被允许对某事发笑，几乎会自动激起你想笑的欲望。嗯，是的。这可以说是整个运作周期的一部分。绝对是的。你知道，而且毕竟，毕竟，说出那些不能说的话，绝对是宣称自己在“说不可言说之物”的绝佳方式，也是卖出票或打响名气的好办法。别忘了，喜剧就像任何其他艺术形式一样，
exists in a raw world of commerce. We were talking about royal patronage earlier. Now the king doesn't pay for comedians. Everyone pays for their own personal gestures. We live like kings now. We each have the gestures we prefer, the fools we prefer the opinions of who tell us the truths we want to hear so yeah and that but there is relentless there's there's endless churn i mean there wasn't there you know in in my career there was a when i first started out you had to be political and if you
存在于残酷的商业世界中。我们刚才谈到了皇室赞助。现在国王不再为喜剧演员付钱了。每个人都为自己的个人姿态买单。我们现在过得像国王一样。我们每个人都有自己偏爱的姿态，偏爱的丑角，他们说出我们想听的真相，所以，是的，这种循环在不断继续，永无止境。我的意思是，在我刚开始职业生涯的时候，你知道，你必须得有政治性，如果你
weren't there was something really quite wrong with you and then and then sort of vic and bob who for my money were very much channeling a kind of milligan-esque goonish streak um and satirical as well but of course because they're not posh no one would ever call it that um uh they they said no actually you can you can you can muck about if you want and it changed and the and the fashion changed. And then there was a solid, pretty solid decade in the early part of this century where if you didn't do jokes about rape, you were some sort of coward, you know, in terms of edge. And all that sort of thing. These things just, they just change.
没有政治性，那你就真的有点问题了。然后是维克和鲍勃，在我看来，他们很大程度上承袭了米利根式的呆子秀风格，同时也很讽刺，但当然，因为他们不是上流社会出身，所以没有人会把那叫作讽刺。嗯，他们说，不，其实你可以，如果你想的话，你可以胡闹，于是风向变了。然后，在本世纪初，有一段相当长、相当稳固的十年时间里，如果你不讲强奸的笑话，你在追求边缘化方面就会被认为是个懦夫，诸如此类。这些事情就是这样，它们一直在变。
The moment something's taboo, comics, because after all, a lot of them are driven by mischief, if nothing else, are drawn to these taboo subjects magnetically. And sometimes they're not. Sometimes you just think, well, an audience won't stomach this. And after all, it's a it's a pas de deux with an audience, the whole thing. And I'll we're all here to have a good time, aren't we? Rather than be confronted about the truth all the time, which is, one of the what one of the means to the ends and there's a very often a confusion between means and ends in comedy anyway the end is to make people laugh and you get there any way you can there's no right way or or perhaps the end of comedy is to uh instill in people a general sense of a historical period this at any rate is the argument of robert mantel who asks
每当有什么事成了禁忌，喜剧演员们——毕竟他们中的许多人除了别的之外，往往是被恶作剧的心态所驱动的——就会像磁铁一样被这些禁忌话题吸引。有时他们不会。有时你只是觉得，嗯，观众消化不了这个。而且毕竟，整件事就是与观众的一场双人舞，我们来到这里都是为了开开心心的，不是吗？而不是时刻去面对冷酷的真相，这就是目的的手段之一，在喜剧中，手段和目的往往会被混淆，反正目的就是为了让人笑，你可以用任何你能想到的方法达到目的，没有正确的方法，或者，也许喜剧的目的在于，嗯，在人们心中灌输一种对某个历史时期的总体感觉？无论如何，这就是罗伯特·曼德尔的观点，他问道：
how much do you think comedy shapes popular views of history for example how much of our view of the first world war is black adder or of roman judea is python um he says it feels like comic takes often have a broader reach and more staying power than serious dramas well that's a very good that's interesting isn't it that's an excellent question and um and i think what's really interesting about that i think is that it's black out of four that's the one that that um i don't think anyone looks at black at the second series of black out of queen elizabeth and thinks oh that's what elizabethan england was like i don't think there's any any feeling of verisimilitude in in in that and i don't think the georgian i don't know that's three that's the last thing people have with the Prince Regents, isn't it?
你认为喜剧在多大程度上塑造了大众对历史的看法？例如，我们对第一次世界大战的看法有多少来自于《黑爵士》？或者我们对罗马犹太地区的看法有多少来自于《巨蟒》？他说，感觉喜剧的角度往往比正剧覆盖面更广，也更持久。嗯，这真是一个很好的问题，很有意思，不是吗？这是一个极好的问题，而且，嗯，我认为其中真正有趣的是，我觉得是《黑爵士4》，那是那个，嗯，我觉得没有人会看着《黑爵士》第二季里的伊丽莎白女王，然后想：哦，伊丽莎白时代的英国就是那个样子的。我认为里面没有任何真实感可言，我不认为乔治王朝时期……等等，那是第三季，那是人们联想到摄政王的最后一季，对吧？
Well, yeah, for my money, I think it's as good as any other history I've read or seen of that period. It's quite differing to the Prince Regents, isn't it? It is actually, yeah. But then, because Blackadder 4 occupies this... I mean, it's very interesting that
嗯，是的，在我看来，我觉得它和我看过或见过的关于那个时期的任何其他历史一样好。它对摄政王的描写相当别具一格，不是吗？其实是的。但随后，因为《黑爵士4》占据了这样一个……我的意思是，非常有趣的是，
the First World War was kind of in living memory when they made it but it was also firmly in living myth by then like any proper big historical event in this country all sorts of established things that were true about it
第一次世界大战在他们拍摄时还算是人们活生生的记忆，但到那时它也已经牢牢地变成活生生的神话了，就像这个国家所有重大的历史事件一样，关于它有各种各样既定的真相。
Gary Sheffield who's the guy at Wolverhampton who wrote Forgotten Victory he's made all sorts of and he's written Hague's biography. And he's, you know, loath to call him a revisionist of First World War history. But he finds, he says, you know, Blackadder, the problem is when you're trying to teach
加里·谢菲尔德，就是那个在沃尔夫哈普顿写了《被遗忘的胜利》的家伙，他提出了各种各样的观点，他还写了黑格的传记。而且他，你知道，很不情愿别人称他为一战历史的修正主义者。但他发现，他说，你知道，《黑爵士》带来的问题是，当你试图教授一战历史时，你很难绕过《黑爵士》。你知道，史蒂芬·弗赖说“明天我们将把前线推进一英寸，然后今天我们再退回一英寸”，或者诸如此类的话。人们真的以为事情就是那样发生的。这可能看起来像是一个稻草人谬论，哦，好吧，因为他们看了《黑爵士》，所以这就是人们对第一次世界大战的看法。但是，你知道，你我都懂历史。历史不属于那些写历史书的人。
First World War history is getting past Blackadder. You know, Stephen Fry saying we'll move, you know, the general melt ship will move forward an inch tomorrow and then we'll move back an inch today or whatever it is. And that that's what people really do think happened. And it can seem like a straw man that, oh, well, they saw Blackadder. So that's what people think of the First World War. But, you know, you and I both know history. History does not belong to the people who write history books.
他们只拥有历史的百分之十。历史往往存在于如此多的言论和叙事中，它既是你作为国家对自己的讲述，也是其他任何事情，或者你是什么样的人，反映了你喜欢什么样的历史，你对世界历史的看法取决于你是什么样的人、你的价值观以及诸如此类的事情。我认为《黑爵士》是一部对塑造人们的一战观念有着强大影响力的节目。如果没有那个结局，它就不会有这么大影响力。我正要这么说，托马斯。
They have they have 10 percent of the ownership of what of what history is history so often exists in in so much discourse that that it's the story you tell about yourselves as a country as much as as much as anything else or the kind of person you are reflects the kind of history you like and your view of world history is what kind of person you are and your values and all that sort of stuff and i I think Blackadder is such a powerful programme for shaping people's ideas of the First World War. And it wouldn't have been as powerful without the end. I was just about to say that, Thomas.
不，不，不。那是最后五分钟。因为这是一部喜剧节目，它敢于做大多数情景喜剧从未做过的事，那就是杀死所有角色。我曾与制作那个系列的导演合作过，他说那是他做出的决定之一，他说：“这就是我们应该做的。”这甚至直接上报到了BBC的高层。
No, no, no. It's the last five minutes. Because it's a comedy programme daring to do something that most sitcoms never did, which is kill off all the characters. And I worked with the director who made that series. And he said that was one of those decisions where he said, this is what we should do. And it went right to the top of the BBC.
我们不能这么做。这是一部喜剧节目。别荒谬了。但他们还是这么做了。然后，当然，BBC高层的每个人都为他们出色的创意决定击掌庆祝。不过，是的，我的意思是，喜剧，喜剧是一个极好的，我的意思是，我想，你知道，我的意思是，比起《角斗士》，我宁愿看《布赖恩的一生》来体会罗马帝国可能是什么样子的。嗯，有趣的是，嗯，嗯，《布赖恩的一生》，我认为它其实非常像——哈喽，哈喽——它是一部对正剧的恶搞，而不是对某种东西的恶搞，我的意思是它是对某种题材的恶搞，诸如此类，但它，我们，我们上周做了一期关于帝国的节目，对吧，然后我们一次又一次被问到各种变体的“罗马人究竟为我们做过什么？”以及关于“帝国到底是好是坏”的整个争论，那是总是被提起的一句台词。而且，每当出现任何形式的政治派别之争时，总是会提到“犹太人民阵线”。这两句台词具有任何伟大戏剧那样的持久力，它们将难以置信的历史复杂性总结为一种方便的简写，然后，是的，它们被争论，它们就像推特上的表情包一样，你知道，它们把事情总结得清清楚楚，啪的一下，你知道的。喜剧演员活着就是为了寻找那种能产生共鸣、能产生深刻影响的东西，你知道，如果你能成功塞进这样一个梗，你就会——我的意思是，我依然认为我喜欢《布赖恩的一生》的原因是，你知道，派森剧团在此之前的产品一直有点像那种，你知道，
We can't do that. It's a comedy program. Don't be ridiculous. And they did it anyway. And then, of course, everyone in the brass at the BBC high-fived themselves for their brilliant creative decision but yes i mean yeah comedy is comedy is an excellent i mean i think you know i mean i'd much rather watch life of brian than gladiator to to get a sniff of what roman uh the roman empire might have been like well it's it's interesting that that um the uh the life of brian which i think is actually very like hello hello it's it's it's a parody of of a drama rather than of say you know i mean it's a parody of sort of stuff yeah and all that kind of stuff but it um we did we did an episode last week on empires yeah and um we got asked again and again kind of variations of what have the romans ever
打破类型，写没有笑点的短剧，并且总的来说展现出他们是多么出色的喜剧天才，非常感谢，然后他们所做的是，他们把一个主题、一个实际的主题塞进他们的绞肉机里，出来的就是《布赖恩的一生》，这是最具连贯性的作品，里面有着令人难以置信的、隐藏在显眼处的思想，诸如此类，我认为这真的太棒了，是的，还有对宗教的探讨，以及《圣杯》也是，是的，是的，《圣杯》也是，是的，是的，《圣杯》在结构上简直不可思议，你知道的，因为我们也做了一期关于亚瑟王的节目，基本上整个主题就是它是如何由各种各样不同的碎片拼凑而成的，而《圣杯》解构这一切的方式正是如此，简直太棒了，对，对，对，这表明最好的电影证明了喜剧可以，你知道，如果你把握得当，当然，可以像任何正剧一样阐明同样深刻的道理。你知道，关于亚瑟王或什么的严肃正剧。但是一部喜剧电影却能找到它，你知道，“圣手榴弹”是一个极其搞笑的想法。安提阿的圣手榴弹是一个极其搞笑的想法。阿尔，让我问你这个。在某种程度上，虽然你显然对喜剧的近代史和喜剧的历史进行了很多思考，但当我们讲述喜剧的近代史时，是否存在这样一种危险：我们有时会过度强调喜剧演员觉得好笑的东西？或者说，文化精英们觉得好笑的东西？而不是那些……你赌对了！所以让我举个例子。如果你把《年轻人》的收视率——显然这部剧很有影响力——和《嗨-迪-嗨》进行对比，这两者简直有着天壤之别。
done for us and on the whole debate about you know our empire's good things or bad things that is the line that always gets brought up and also whenever there's any kind of political factionalism it's always Judean people's front and those two lines have the kind of sticking power of you know any great drama they sum up incredible historical complexities in a kind of convenient shorthand that can then yes they're debated they're like they're like a meme on twitter you know that they sum the thing up bosh they you know and comedians live for a thing that um that lands that lands uh uh lands like that um you know if you can if you can just get one thing through like that you you've i mean the i mean i still think what i love about life of brian is that you know python's output up to them had been up to then a bit of them sort of you know
《嗨-迪-嗨》受欢迎得多，可以说它更能反映80年代初的英国人觉得什么好笑。现在，这可能会让很多人感到反感，因为他们会觉得，好吧，《嗨-迪-嗨》是垃圾，是主流，而《年轻人》要前卫得多、有趣得多。
breaking breaking genres and uh and uh writing sketches without punch lines and and generally just showing what brilliant um comic minds they were thank you very much and then they what they do is they then feed a subject an actual subject into their uh mincer and out comes life of brian which is the most coherent thing with incredibly you know ideas hidden hidden in plain sight and all that sort of stuff that i think is really just a fantastic yeah and and the discussion of religion and holy grail as well yeah yeah holy grail as well yeah yeah holy grail which is incredible in kind of the structuring you know because we've done an episode on arthur as well and basically the whole theme of that was how it you know it's made up
但那个角色，格拉迪斯·皮尤，不就是她暗恋的那个人吗？对，西蒙·卡德尔。那个经营度假营的人。西蒙·卡德尔。对，他是个皇家空军飞行员，对吧？所以他是经历过战争的。我想他是个……不，不，不。
from all kinds of different bits and the way in which holy grail just completely destructs deconstructs the whole thing and exactly that kind of it's brilliant yeah yeah yeah and it shows the best film about demonstrates that comedy can can you know, if you get it right, of course, you know, can shed as much light as any drama ever could. You know, a serious drama about King Arthur, whatever. But a comedy film that sort of finds it, you know, the Holy Hand Grenade is an incredibly funny idea. The Holy Hand Grenade of Antioch is an incredibly funny idea. Al, let me ask you this. Is there an extent to which though, I mean, you obviously think a lot about the recent history
西蒙·卡德尔不是，不。他是吉尔斯·布兰德瑞斯的同龄人，吉尔斯是他的朋友。不，不，他不，西蒙·古德尔不是，不。他是吉尔斯·布兰德瑞斯的同龄人，吉尔斯是他的朋友。不，但是那个角色，他演的那个角色，对，那个角色是个失败的，我想他是剑桥大学的导师什么的，对吧？他离开学术界去经营一个度假营，对吧。哦，也许是这样，我的意思是，我想对你说的，多米尼克，两个我都喜欢，当然，我的意思是，我不是说你不能两个都喜欢，但是，但是，但是，是的，也许吧，但我们所讲述的故事往往强调前卫感和打破边界。
of comedy and the history of comedy generally. But when we tell the recent history of comedy, is there a danger that we sometimes overemphasise things that comedians find funny? Or things that, as it were, cultural elites find funny? Rather than things that... You bet! So let me give you an example. If you were to compare the viewing figures
新奇感。是的，追求“新奇带来的震惊”，而不是“陈旧带来的震惊”，你知道，也就是大卫·埃杰顿关于技术的那个论点，你知道，20世纪30年代设计的踏板车至今仍在世界各地到处都是，
of The Young Ones, which obviously was very influential, and Heidi High, I mean, they're chalk and cheese. Heidi High was colossally more popular and arguably tells you more about what early 80s Britain found funny. Now, that may be distasteful to a lot of people because they think, well, Heidi High is rubbish and mainstream and Young Ones is much edgier and more interesting.
但没有人对它们感兴趣。它们远没有其他任何东西那么吸引人。好吧，我觉得，你知道，我的意思是，如果你现在看《年轻人》，我已经好久没看过了，我记得那部剧给我的感觉就像是被一把五颜六色的笑声锤子狠狠砸在脑袋上。当我15岁的时候，看这个节目简直是非同寻常的体验，它绝对要为我后来对喜剧产生兴趣负上全责，不亚于任何其他因素。我觉得它现在可能看起来和当时一样过时，不，它不过时，我看了，我上周刚看过，奇怪的是，我看了第一季，当你没有什么更好的事情可做时，去看老版的《年轻人》，它是如此之好。我，嗯，我突然发现自己不知不觉中一直在为英国盒子付费，我显然在某个时刻按错了按钮，所以我想，好吧，我总得从里面捞点本回来，所以我随便点开，然后我突然就在想同样的事情：当年的《年轻人》真的像我记忆中那么好笑吗？事实上，它们更好笑，它们更尖酸刻薄，它们更具冲击力，而且它们似乎——里面蕴含的东西比你作为一个……时所注意到的要多。
But wasn't the guy, Gladys Pugh, the one she was in love with? Yeah, Simon Cadell. The guy who runs the company. Simon Cadell. Yeah, he was a RAF pilot, wasn't he? So he was from the war. I think he was a... No, no, no.
是的，是的，是的，多得多。我觉得它经受住了时间的考验，虽然我觉得，我也很喜欢《嗨-迪-嗨》，我想如果我看了《嗨-迪-嗨》，里面也会有更多我小时候没有意识到的东西，比如人际关系、紧张局势以及诸如此类你可能不会注意到的东西，你知道的。好吧，我知道，我觉得你是，我觉得，多米尼克，我觉得这是一个非常非常好的问题，而且你完全，多米尼克，我觉得这是一个非常非常好的问题。而且你完全正确。我的意思是，广播界发生变化的地方，当然，
Simon Cadell wasn't, no. He was a contemporary of Giles Brandreth, who was a friend of his. No no he know there simon goodell wasn't no he was a he was a contemporary of uh giles brandreth who's a friend of his no but the character he played the character yeah the character is a failed i think he's cambridge don or something isn't he he leaves academia to run a holiday camp yeah oh maybe that's i mean what what i'd say to you dominic is i like them both of course i mean i'm not saying you can't like them both but but but but yes well maybe but the story that we tell tends to emphasise edginess and pushing boundaries.
是我们谈论的是一个最多只有四个频道的时代。所以你要么看《嗨-迪-嗨》，要么看我的电视。对，但这里有一个有趣的点。汤姆和我曾做过一个关于90年代的播客，我们谈到了文化的碎片化。90年代是拥有集体文化、流行文化的最后一个节点。是的。那么我们是否失去了集体喜剧文化？嗯，这是过去30年里广播界发生的一件非常有趣的事情。我的意思是，丹尼斯·诺顿也说过，当他在战后开始写喜剧时，起步并让观众发笑是轻而易举的事，因为每个人都经历过相同的事情。
A novelty. Yes, shock of the new rather than the shock of the old, you know, which is that David Edgerton argument about technology, you know, that scooters designed in the 1930s are all over the world still,
每个人都经历过第二次世界大战。所以他们所有人对它都有看法，都有一些共同的经历，而且他们也都有一个巨大的、共同的经历，你知道，因此你可以确信，如果你写了一个关于配给制的笑话，它一定会以这样或那样的方式触动所有人，他们都会对此有所反应。而且我认为有趣的是，也许我们正要进入一个时期，嗯，嗯，这和那个有点类似，因为我们都经历过同样的事情。我的意思是，很显然，很多喜剧演员会想，好吧，无论我做什么，你知道，如果在爱丁堡边缘艺术节上，会有一大群人说：“我绝对不要谈论该死的封锁。我绝对不提。我要写别的东西，别的，任何东西，”因为观众已经对封锁感到厌烦了。
but no one's interested in them. They're nowhere near as fascinating as anything. Well, I think, well, you know, I mean, I think if you watch the young ones now, and I haven't seen it in ages, and I remember that show being like bashed over the head with a sort of Technicolor laugh hammer. It was the most extraordinary thing to watch when I was 15 and is entirely responsible for me being interested
他们不想谈论这个。但也许我们需要进行一次伟大的，你知道的，喜剧式的安全阀式的宣泄。我不知道。而且我认为，我认为，是的，我们在喜剧上绝对更加多元化了，尽管我们，我的意思是，你知道，流传的那些标准叙事之一就是“你再也不能拿任何东西开玩笑了”。但现在你可以开玩笑的东西，是你20年前、40年前、60年前根本无法拿来开玩笑的，题材的大爆发以及实际上禁忌的松动。结果证明，男孩女孩们，现在只有一两样东西是你们不能再拿来开玩笑了，其实就是这样。
in comedy as much as as much as any other thing i think it might look as dated now as as it doesn't it doesn't i watched it i watched it last week oddly i watched the first series and you have nothing better to do than watch old series of the young ones it was so good i i well i suddenly discovered that i'd inadvertently been paying for brit box i obviously pressed the wrong button at some point so i thought well i might as well get something out of it so i'll just and i suddenly i was thinking exactly that what were the young ones as funny as i remembered it actually they were funnier and they were more scabrous and they were more shocking and they seemed so there was more going on than you might have noticed as
而题材、方法、角度、手法和风格的纯粹范围，就像是一场无限的大爆炸。但这难道不是——难道在某种程度上这不会带来一种损害吗？因为一个社会也许需要去嘲笑同样的笑话，嘲笑同样的事情。我的意思是，很显然，你，我们永远不会回到那个莫克姆和怀斯的圣诞特辑时代，当时有3000万人都在看同一个节目。但我觉得这就像把50年代看作核心家庭的黄金时代一样。那只是个特例。只有一段很短的时期，
a yes yeah yes a lot more i thought it really held up although i think that i loved i loved hidey-hide as well i think i expect if i watched hidey-hide there'd be more going on than i realized as a kid too that there was a lot going on relationships and tensions and all that sort of stuff that you wouldn't wouldn't spot you know well i know i think you're i think dominic i think i think that's an a really good a really good question um and you're absolutely Dominic, I think that's a really good question. And you're absolutely right. I mean, the thing that's changed in broadcasting, of course,
在电视出现之前，广播喜剧曾盛极一时，大概只有10年，也就是50年代，当时每个人都听同一个广播节目。然后每个人都看同一个电视节目。而现在，你知道，每个人都在YouTube上。我的意思是，这其中很大一部分本来就是技术造成的。回到音乐厅盛行的时代，并不是每个人都在笑同样的东西，因为当时没有传播手段来创造那种我们都能理解的“全国性笑话”的概念。其实，阿尔，当时有更多地区性的笑话。
is that we're talking about a time when there were four channels, max. And so you either watched Heidi High or you watched one at my TV. Yeah, but here's an interesting thing. Tom and I had a podcast about the 90s, and we were talking about the fragmentation of culture. So the 90s being the last point where you had a collective culture, popular culture. Yeah. And have we lost a collective comedic culture? Well, that's a that's a really interesting thing. in broadcasting that's happened in the last 30 years. I mean, and also that Dennis Norton said that when he started writing comedy after the war, it was dead easy to get going and to make an audience laugh because everyone had been through the same thing.
人们根本听不懂伦敦、利物浦和曼彻斯特的笑话。甚至互相听不懂。你知道，查理·卓别林在去美国之前在湖区作为证人被传唤时，他们以为他是法国人，因为他们根本听不懂他在说什么。
Everyone had been through the Second World War. So to they all had they all had an opinion on it and they all had some shared experience but they also had a big the big shared experience you know uh and so you could with assurance know that you if you wrote a joke about rationing uh that it would land with everyone one way or another that they'd all have some reaction to it and i think interestingly maybe we're about to enter a period of um uh uh that's a bit similar to that because we have all been through the same thing i mean obviously obviously what a lot of comics will think right whatever i do uh you know if there's an edinburgh fringes here there'll be a whole lot of people going, I'm absolutely not going to talk about bloody lockdown. I'm not going to mention it. I'm going to write about something else, something, anything else, because audiences were sick of lockdown.
阿尔，阿尔，你提到了丹尼斯·诺顿。是的。我能顺便向我的朋友杰米·缪尔致意吗？他的父亲弗兰克·缪尔写了丹尼斯·诺顿。是的。我能顺便向我的朋友杰米·缪尔致意吗？他的父亲弗兰克·缪尔写了丹尼斯·诺顿。他们一起写出了喜剧历史上最伟大的台词之一。在《罗马艳后》里。
They won't want to talk about it. But it may be that there needs to be a great, you know, safety valve letting out of letting off of steam that needs to happen comedically. I don't know. And I think i think but i think yes we definitely are much more it's much more comically diverse although we i mean you know the the one of the standard narratives that's doing the range you can't talk you can't joke about anything anymore the stuff you can joke about now that you couldn't joke about uh you know 20 years ago 40 years ago, 60 years ago, the explosion in subject matter and actually a loosening of stuff. There's only one or two things you can't joke about anymore, boys and girls, you know, is actually what it comes down to.
冲着我来的。冲着我来的。冲着我来的。冲着我来的。他们全冲着我来了。所以这是送给你的，杰米，如果你在听这个的话。我想我们得在这里拉上帷幕了。我想我们已经够娱乐大家了。阿尔，太感谢了。
And the sheer range of subject matter approaches and angles and methods and styles it's like it's it's an infinite explosion but isn't that isn't that sort of sort of damaging to an extent that a society maybe needs to laugh at the same jokes laugh at the same things i mean obviously you're we're never going to get back to that world of the more common wise christ Christmas special where 30 million people have watched the same. But I think that's like looking at the 50s as a golden age of the nuclear family. That's the anomaly. There's only been a short period.
这绝对太精彩了。我们下周见。我不记得我们要聊什么了。哦，我们要聊美国化，对吧，多曼？是的，没错。我们在聊世界是如何变成美国的。以及它正在变得“反美”吗？
There's only 10 years, really, where radio comedy was enormous before TV came along, the 50s, when everyone listened to the same radio program. And then everyone watched the same TV program. And now, you know, everyone's on YouTube. I mean, so much of this is technological anyway. Back when there was Music Hall, not everyone was laughing at the same stuff because there was no means of transmission to create that idea of national jokes that we all understood. Actually, Al, there were much more regional jokes.
以及它正在变得“反美”吗？所以我们到时见。阿尔，真的。我们在聊世界是如何变成美国的。以及它正在变得“反美”吗？以及它正在变得“反美”吗？所以我们到时见。阿尔，非常感谢。绝对是种荣幸。谢谢你，阿尔。谢谢各位。感谢收听《历史就是这样》。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告体验，
People wouldn't understand the jokes in London and Liverpool and Manchester. Or even each other. You know, Charlie Chaplin, when he's called as a witness in the Lake District before he goes to America, they think he's French because they can't understand what he's saying.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
Al, Al, your mention of Dennis Norton. Yes. Can I just give a shout out to my friend Jamie Muir, whose dad, Frank Muir, wrote Dennis Norton. Yes. Can I just give a shout out to my friend Jamie Muir, whose dad, Frank Muir, wrote Dennis Norton. And together they wrote what must surely be the greatest line from any comedy about history. Carry on, Cleo. In for me.
阿尔，阿尔，你提到了丹尼斯·诺顿。是的。我能顺便向我的朋友杰米·穆尔（Jamie Muir）致意吗？他的父亲弗兰克·穆尔（Frank Muir）写了《丹尼斯·诺顿》。是的。我能顺便向我的朋友杰米·穆尔致意吗？他的父亲弗兰克·穆尔写了《丹尼斯·诺顿》。他们俩一起写了喜剧历史上最棒的一句台词：《公元前克利奥帕特拉》（Carry on Cleo）。冲着我来的。
In for me. In for me. In for me. They've all got it in for me. So that's for you, Jamie, if you're listening to this. I think we need to pull the curtain down here. We've, I guess, entertained you all enough. Al, thanks so much.
冲着我来的。冲着我来的。冲着我来的。他们全冲着我来。所以这是给你的，杰米，如果你正在听这个节目的话。我想我们得在这里落下帷幕了。我想我们已经招待大家够久了。阿尔，非常感谢。
That was absolutely brilliant. We will be back next week. I can't remember what we're talking about. Oh, we're talking about Americanisation, aren't we, Dorman? We are. Yeah, we are. We're talking about how the world became American. And is it becoming un-American?
这绝对太精彩了。我们下周会回来。我不记得我们要谈论什么了。哦，我们在谈论美式化，对吧，多曼？是的，我们是的。我们在谈论世界是如何变成美国的。以及它是否正在变得非美国化？
And is it becoming un-American? So we will see you then. Al, we are. We're talking about how the world became American. And is it becoming un-American? And is it becoming un-American? So we will see you then. Al, thanks so much. A total pleasure. Thanks, Al. Thanks, gents. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
以及它是否正在变得非美国化？所以我们到时见。阿尔，非常感谢。非常荣幸。谢谢你，阿尔。谢谢各位。感谢收听《历史滑铁卢》。想要收听独家番外、提前解锁、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。